today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza great block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles gray block
get that hitter what's up guys happy
Thanksgiving to you and yours we are
thankful for you here and for being here
with us whenever you're consuming this
time this this this episode as well
Happy Thanksgiving Nick wanted to say
something to you guys I just want to say
Happy Thanksgiving to all the listeners
and and you enjoy that turkey and that
tryptophan that tryptophan dude look
that's free dope isn't it yeah that's
white people dilip according to our
guest today that's true that's white
people dope according to our guest today
today's guest is a friend of mine he's a
confidant he's a he's a retired US
military servicemen he's retired but I
mean he ain't fighting and a you know he
is someone that I look up to and no
doubt he is one of the funniest people
that I know he's coming to tour in the
next few weeks I think in Indianapolis
Minneapolis and we'll have all those
dates below and we'll have all those
dates below right and Detroit I think it
is actually you may know him as ashy
Larry from the Chappelle show it's my
friend mr. Donnell Rawlings
[Music]
I'm not obsessing you are yeah because
you've been trying to get me a Cummins
Pat podcast for probably I'll say like
roughly like a year yeah and then part
of the lore but we're friends I will
come on anyway who's like yeah we take
care about people we send cars for them
and everything up and if I remember I
drove myself to your podcast today yeah
and I talked to all my all your other
friends the white people and everybody
else had cars yeah I'm just trying to
get a clear understanding on why I
couldn't get a car and not only that I
couldn't get a car I know that your
guests come up in you offering beverages
yeah like on like mint tea we know and
and I'm a little upset because I don't
know if this is racist whatever the
cucumber part is definitely white okay
the watermelon part there was it like
like did you guys like who's responsible
for giving a black guy there's a survey
online it says if you look up flavors
there that you know or people like right
whatever people mean people you know
from from inner city from from the city
and overall specific shade or just
anybody
I mean is it reserved just a Latino
supplies I just want you and the reason
why I want to get to bottom-up I
consider you to be a dear friend yeah
and I know you went through some legal
issues about a week ago yeah I did as
like as as all of us always do it and
you they got you to say yeah I got you
and you get time you don't say yeah and
I was excited to be here cuz I know if I
could come to your pockets that means
you're home yeah you free yeah first off
is good to see thank you and that's it I
brought you some gifts
oh damn that's what's up it's almost
like a care package mostly you will
probably need this when you was in the
joint but I got to these things coming
out to join cuz I care about respect man
I don't you can save for later you can
show people
I'll show people man yeah I think open
it all right yeah we got that Hamburger
Helper boy Alice berry
yeah I couldn't do you gotta help
yourself with the hamburger I didn't get
the hamburger
kind of my blood so that's the start
that's that started packs of cigarettes
you get in the joint well you know cuz
you was in a joint I mean that
cigarettes you could get for one box and
probably two pegs now that's two packs
of Marlboro Lights
yeah his black people I'm really smoked
them too much but you could get a cart
in the Newports that's just just just
for you'll know the next time you have
respect man I really appreciate that
let me see this second item oh that ROM
and now another favor will you came from
sir that's where if you meet Oh meet
somebody in the joint you could treat
him to something at that yeah if you got
to pot to boil you what you know how
y'all yeah oh I'll cook in the toilet
usually but I wanted you to I you know
just coming home I didn't I didn't want
to put your face that you was locked up
and I still want you to know that people
know what you're which what I was going
through my struggle and this right there
that rich and creamy boy and those were
two dudes that I met in the joint
actually what the creamy but you know
I'm said I don't like to use you just
came over as you can't use when you
locked up rich or cream here but I just
thought you don't you know you probably
didn't have like desserts so you ain't
even got it open and it's in his eye I
couldn't get a new one
oh damn yeah I felt like it was leaking
it's the law but it's still gonna say
they just put on your thumb and go to
work so yeah that's that baby bad huh
yeah that's definitely man that's that
little treat and what is this oh one
avocado what you got with all the other
stuff I get you will just sort of make a
salad I gotta keep you keep you healthy
at the same time like that out of
SpaghettiOs that's what Thanksgiving
that's a specialty you don't that's not
no every day every day who does the
noodles you can eat those every day but
yeah but if somebody care about you too
soon you get now we're talkin good stuff
right here and what is this that's
mascara I don't know which was into when
you are just hang yeah yeah if you want
to get back in touch or I don't know you
got nice outros you might want to touch
them up that might not be for the
streets that just for the [ __ ] sign
yeah no I'll put some of this on some
time especially if I go back in oh and I
got this power cable too
yeah cuz I know you probably didn't have
access to your phone and I'm gonna tell
you in a gift bag everybody some point
they want a extra cord yeah and that's
the iPhone charger too so I get I got
you that cuz I care about you oh thanks
man this is awesome dude and have you do
you is it common if you have
like friends like buddies of yours that
you'll give them like some people we do
you guys deal a lot and like do you give
is that a common thing if you see a like
a friend yeah you know or a black guy
who's gotten out of jail do you give
them something is there like a usual
gift you'll get me the best thing you
want to give them is advice yeah
a lot I don't usually take that and
that's the reason why they're why the
Indian so slaughter my boy said man [ __ ]
all that advice what you guys don't some
in the back yeah and when you come home
even if you wasn't really connected that
person you know like coming home as a
big deal in yeah so you try to show us
unlike some people give up money clothes
whatever but I'm not you know feeling
like that so I try to give our little
care packages and beautify took the time
out for you son
I appreciate it man thank you very much
as do you probably one of my sixty or
seventy favorite you know diverse
friends that I have or probably
maybe even top 20 top 10 I don't really
believe that you have 67 and I don't
want to I don't wanna I don't want to
blow you up if I just said name them
naming me three times isn't that the
same thing and also you can't use the
wu-tang because nobody know how many
wu-tang anybody know how many wu-tang
clan's it's little wounds I got a new
clan man they got a new clan e-town
I had Frederick Douglas on that list too
man so it goes deep yeah I see you took
you really pay attention on black
history Michael would even know
Frederick Douglass was unless so I
appreciate you for being in the place
you know in a school where they taught
you what Freddie does work yeah that's
dope where are you uh were you playing
at next I'm gonna I got a tour now the
funny moves tour we started Live Nation
i team allowed nation mm-hmm and they're
doing some small theater tsukai make the
transition from nightclub to the theater
our first stop is uh Detroit
I think Detroit is on its 29th it moves
closer the Detroit is like back if you
want yeah however you want Detroit
oh oh I'm black so I gotta leave that
you got a recliner damn black you can't
I feel like you can't where else okay
you said Detroit I want to get through
that I got a mini Annapolis yeah any
opera Annapolis
yeah fact about 30
was that way Indianapolis sign like once
you go past three or four syllables I
get stuck you know I'm clapping min-hee
Annapolis it's too many for me but y'all
know what it is rather that gang dude
that's it gang gang oh he's in huh yeah
what do black people think about six
nine they like I mean it's interesting
because like he's he's like he's hike
anytime anybody represents Brooklyn you
know brothers want to attach yourself to
that he's grimy but this the same things
there are street things that people I
guess got connected with him is the
reason why yo he's locked up now ya know
I don't wish death or prison on anybody
but you know I'm saying you got it no
something's will happen to when you
invite people to suck your dick yeah
[ __ ] yarders [ __ ] yeah we got yes and
it's so easy for the FBI and these
tactical unit Stefani's people cuz all I
gotta do is follow more Instagram yeah
you know saying how do we know y'all was
gonna be gangbang in Chicago cuz you
said pull up in Chicago right you know
so I wish the best for my ripp respect
the fact that a kid at his age could
stroll enough where they could put
himself in a situation they got
financial gains yeah they popular in and
he made it you may the same time the
same things that you got probably for
could be to definitely so yeah for all
the trolls I did be careful do you think
he's like the rainbow Bobby shmurda kind
of a little bit it's murder
sorry it's like no you gotta take the
ERL of sec you can't you can't do like
sh murder in where it would the earth at
the end of it I don't use it murder
yeah goodbye murder and Bobby shmurda
was the blueprint on how to get locked
up yeah and I from like the same area
Brooke I just don't understand why six
nine and see it but you know I wish him
wishing well don't drop the soap son and
you know hopefully you know the
situation where the public can see him
one of the care package that I sent you
yeah that's a good point actually we
should make a Bobby shmurda uh we should
make uh us we should make a six nine
care package in Sim one yeah have you
lost
rainbows skittles yes we gonna look like
when he gets out though do you think uh
there's the rainbow fade over time
I don't know well if he comes out he
looks like
we know something tragic happen we know
that he did he didn't have
soap-on-a-rope you know yeah but the
thing about it he's only been he's only
been charged yeah I'm saying now here's
the thing if for some reason you know
none of these nummies charges stick
which is highly unlikely yeah cuz the
feds have 97 percent conviction rate if
he beats it then like he's gonna be
mortal man in the streets yeah you know
I'm like you know and like white kids
they could do two weeks in prison and
come out and have a number one wrap up
yeah follow is some here you see it for
hours all you need to do is get two
gunshot wounds you know I've said you
just shot three or four I think the four
I think the number to be respecting the
streets get shot four times and you just
coming home up before I would be and you
get shot four times so you could go
platinum I was stuck in traffic longer
than it was then I was in there man and
that's the whole thing I know for you to
like get a four hour sentence and drive
eight hours when you got off the bus it
was time sir but you was hard you came
back you different so I got tattoos oh I
feel different man you should feel
different man have you ever been locked
up or not yep
really 48 damn hours damn it was who was
in there you remember anybody that was
in there it was it was just
[ __ ] yeah and um it was just it
was just [ __ ] in I did 48 hours
and uh you know it was tough I didn't
have no weapon I had because they gave
us you know about this they gave us one
little boxes of frosted flakes yeah and
you get a sport you know a sport oh yeah
yeah it's like it's um spoon across
between the spoon and a fork so I don't
have a shank but in the can they don't
know if you got a [ __ ] yeah so what you
do is I had two spoke behind me like I
was the [ __ ] yeah I would you know and
then I would test it and I think they
went nerve too scared because I would
test my shank on the wall and it would
it would Bend
the play so it wasn't that gang so I
wasn't for 48 hours you never supposed
to tell people what you need for but I
let people know suspended license yeah
suspended license it was one of days
where you know normally when I Drive I
use my blinkers yeah you know
I let my [ __ ] don't make it right but
yeah I was feeling rebellious I wasn't
with that blinkers yeah so I looked
right I turned left police rolled on the
wheat and they came up to me but roll
the window down and I'm the police
looked at me he said I need to see your
driver's license and I looked at him I
said look
y'all took my license two years ago to
tell me I lost my cool
let's Gino I mean he can I did 48 but
you know I came home I got strong I got
God yeah I was a Muslim for two hours
yeah everybody Israelite are you that
yeah that's the new thing I've now
because I used to have a thing for white
chicks so it's hard to be Israelite and
have jungle fever to say - yeah they
don't they don't go to get it's gotta be
all about the system I like the office
yeah but I like the outfit but the
things they preach whatever I'm not
really for that and I like baking yeah
oh yeah you can't do it yeah growing up
it was it was tough for me with
religions because every time we got
close to religion every time we got
close to a holiday mm-hmm my mother
would change our religion damn is a
morning
yeah like about two weeks before
Christmas we was Muslims waiting for my
birthday we was Jehovah Witnesses uh and
there's no disrespect to God anything I
was like man [ __ ] this man I want a god
to like toys yeah like bacon and like me
to sleep on Saturday yeah God I didn't
really experience any of that until when
I went to the military when I'm in the
military because I was Muslim job Oliver
I went to military I'm in a chow hall
and uh they had a pan of bacon son and
this one I quit being a Muslim yeah and
a bacon egg potatoes and everything it
was like we won I say bacon they said
what else I said bacon yeah they said
what else I said bacon so I'm coming on
the I'm scared and they get up
and I'm bacon DUP so you know no
disrespect to anybody practice you know
was that a Muslim yeah what Islam slams
we call him Slim's where I'm from Slim's
yeah yeah but you know I mean that was
part of my life I got past and not you
pork whenever I want to yeah so I'm
talking about yes is it
I feel like bacon tastes better if
you're a black guy is that true or a
black person and that's not like a
racial thing I just think food seemed
like everything seemed like it tastes
better like music seems like it sounds
better taste better if you are like I
feel like maybe
like you know a fam tastebuds you know
or african-american tastebuds kind of
they just I feel like maybe you guys
hear music differently you might taste
differently the way you interpret things
is different so you said black people
good at important than white people
taste better for black people yes
I don't know about that bro I don't know
about that I would have that you go to
the Midwest what are those crazy why do
is no teeth tobacco yeah what they do
you know you know those guys don't know
they love for it but I'm saying like
black black people I don't know we just
we take it spits and turn white people
y'all put the whole pig on the job we
just want bacon yeah yeah I want to
smell y'all what the hill and everything
but I don't know about but if you look
back historically why people are they
have violent they're violent like that
yeah historic what they done a lot of
stuff I don't wanna get into that I do
want to get into it but yeah but who but
but do you think though that they're do
you really do you think though that
there could really be like a thing where
like black people hear music differently
than what we hear with rhythm yeah you
know I'm saying yeah yeah you know like
a lot of white people they hear with one
and the two and three and four and but
black beer that same thing gonna be like
oh nana yeah but she is just more rhythm
so I think our brains process rhythm a
lot a lot better than the average white
person yeah but you have some like like
white white guys in every neighborhood
there's always one white guy the black
chicks say he could get it Wow you know
and that guys usually the one with the
rhythm it's not extend to the whole
neighborhood but it's always one got
ahead of real I don't think it was you
yeah but I'm pretty sure it's always one
guy
I don't do you think that they have like
do black guys from America look
differently at black guys that come like
say like there's a guy from Jamaica or
there's a guy from like Zaire who just
moved to America what's that
relationship oh man that's what black
guys feel white you know so yeah yeah I
don't know what type of races that don't
say well with somebody saying which
black guy which black guy you want to
date whatever do you got what say me
they were like it
me over here and Deborah always it's a
tough one it's a tough one you don't say
that's a tough that's wild man because
sometimes it's like yeah I'm like those
types of people those black people from
Africa are so different I'd like them
black people from America you know yeah
the go gives the other hostage for sure
yeah their husbands but it's funny like
you if without without hearing a black
person when you see him you have an
instant connection with them yeah you
don't saying do you know you do yeah
yeah you oh you know you like oh that's
might be yeah
but then when I talk like this like this
who are you calling a [ __ ] yeah but
just on the first look on skin whatever
you have like a instant connection well
yeah that's cool man yep I get nervous
um do you want to be black son you ever
thought about it oh yeah I've thought
about it yeah when I was like you know
from age you know 12 to 16 every white
kid does you know so then I definitely
did but now I think I would want to be
Mexican next I think for me black still
seemed a little too risky I would wait
one more another year before you double
another cycle like another life cycle
all right like reincarnated one time be
Latino and there was risky now just
being black or risky dude black like in
a chorus it's still too risky for me I
get nervous a lot I know I have fear and
anxiety yeah yeah yeah if you get
nervous now you wouldn't be good black
yeah not definite you couldn't have no
traffic stop zero do black people get
nervous cuz it always seemed like to me
when I was growing up I honestly don't
know that black people never got I was
like [ __ ] black people do not get nerve
now we do procedure we use different
language like you call it nervous and
then black he might call it shook right
you don't say like he wasn't nervous now
I was it's the same definition where
were you nervous now
I was just little shook yeah I mean we
just don't identify with certain things
like when it comes to uh like depression
yeah white people can identify with
depression anxiety posts whatever post
yeah that stress they could deal with
that you know saying but you as a white
person are you stressed yeah I'm really
stressed yes white person you stressed
eustress blackboard like nine stress I'm
just a little [ __ ] up is the word you
use you know say and I know like like
Charlemagne the guy has his book cause
[ __ ] one and he was talking about
distinct more black people dealing with
mid to issues I'm saying and he's as a
person he sent from president pan a
therapist a hundred dollars hour to talk
to him about problems yeah I was black
person from the hood can't afford a
therapist right good for is a bag we
yeah a bottle of Hennessy and that's
what we look through that's how we get
get we deal with mental issues it's not
the way it should be but we don't use
the same words because you get different
drugs you don't say when you say when
you say I'm a little stressed out
anxiety you get prozac xanax and all
that type [ __ ] if you say that to a
black person you get we see why might
try to give you a LAN and blow you're
saying is that it's not the right thing
to do but it's just different
definitions I say you know oh that's and
all of us below [ __ ] that right now but
the whole thing about being a little
[ __ ] right now it's how you cope with
think coping is is none what they have
to deal with with any mental issues can
you cope with it yeah do they have like
unique mental issues that you think
black guys get that white guys don't get
I don't know if this is a mental issue
but a lot of black guys give a white
guys can't well they can but like jungle
fever yeah you know saying I don't think
that that's a mental disorder but it's
something it's something that's a little
taboo in the black community so is it
scary would you bring a white girl home
to like a black Thanksgiving never I
tried out I tried that once before
and I guess I feel scared almost even
thinking about I wouldn't do that cuz I
did it one time I wear this white chick
home for Thanksgiving and the family
there was at all you know you love his
love and and she showed up to things
give it with a Tater Tot Casserole and
she showed up with white people potato
salad yeah and a potato salad the
ingredients were apple chunks raisins
cinnamon yeah herself I dare hope it but
yeah yeah no no cholesterol you know I
mean if black people really get upset if
you bring the wrong potato salad so I
wouldn't advise bringing a white chick
home for Thanksgiving Christmas is not
Thanksgiving it's a lot of pressure it
is yep dude so I always had these weird
theories you know man and like I don't
think I'm raised it's like a thing I
first saw up anytime someone's doctor
sent it off I don't think I'm it's a
little bit but you got types of raises
the type that people understand at this
time and it's the type to get too [ __ ]
up so what which one were you dealing
with I think there was moments when I
what type of races are you I know what
type do you think you are sir I am the
one I'm trying to be honest about my
racism and try to get in so I can learn
about it and learn from it you know I
think I was I probably was more I
definitely am more racial anger towards
black people when I was younger probably
growing up in this house or ignorance
because ignorance ignorance is the is
the is the breeding ground for races
right when you're ignorant president
leads you in a situation where you could
be racist right I'm saying I may not be
fair I think Mama's fear like cuz I knew
some dudes were ignorant I knew dude
they drove around and like you know [ __ ]
black people you know n-word this and I
wasn't that you know and my mother
wasn't that and my father wasn't that
like you know so but I would get like
you know there was just always you know
like I wrote on the bus with the black
kids to school so it was like you know
the I don't the poorer kids
I don't necessary you know so where was
at the front of the back of the bus this
is goodness um quit I stayed in the
middle right in the back is where we
keep this at the front so yeah the fun
people the people like myself spit balls
airplanes in the back and like people
that would few didn't know which way to
go sat in the middle
yeah sat in the middle man I was scared
but I would get like you know black kids
were like there was like you know kids
would fight the black his role was like
stronger and tougher so I felt like they
were like if there was fights they would
always win the fights and so I think I
just had a lot more fear probably about
you know I got jumped a couple times
like yeah so I think I had more fear but
then also had just as many like buddies
that were
because they were loose like me like
their parents were they were doing
whatever they wanted just with a bike
and just rock but if you got beat up but
I don't care what color person it was I
went racist yeah like if I got jump in
age of 12 by whole bunch of Asians I
would never watch a confident maybe for
the rest of my life so I got a sour Joe
now whatever race beats you up so I
think it just made me scared right but I
think there's also this thing I felt
like but like you wanna this this is
obsession with black culture that people
want to be they want to relate to it so
much it's cool if you go to any other
country whatever the people that they
emulate the most especially like we
hip-hop is black culture yeah I don't
know what is I don't know that it goes
back you know when black folks were all
you know black folks were always in
entertainment I don't know where it
comes from but for some reason people
are curious about that lifestyle yeah
well knowing two black friends is better
than having [ __ ] cable these days
yeah but as far as entertainment goes
knowing to just spending time with you
know black people like to laugh more
they like to there's just more [ __ ]
going on they might know somebody that
got shot like there's just like laughs
harder harder let you do it you do it
I'm a black comedy club you know if they
like yeah you know if you stop it they
let you fill it yeah and it's so weird
because I came up from the black circuit
you know right so I'm used to people do
when I do my shows if you rip it you can
feel it did I start doing the main
street a crossover so and I started
doing white runs and there's some time
it was hard to tell because you'll get a
chuckle they'll point to you like this
no that's funny oh that's a great game
this tooth oh yeah thumbs up and like I
couldn't understand I would do show
sometimes I get on stage I was like I
hate this [ __ ] then kind of like this oh
my god you [ __ ] killed the way you
set up and the premise and the callback
to use I'm like I don't want you to
break down comedy [ __ ]
I want you to laugh but also at black
community in a black comedy club you
have the joke haters yeah the
[ __ ] just angry hey Joe Gators
they almost like the toilet was joking
it's left like this you know you'll say
some funny [ __ ] they like
you good you good you was funny but you
was a funny funny funny funny a white
people white people when they like you
they [ __ ] do get on a Yelp report
yeah do the comment cards if you look at
a comment card a me copy club there's
never gonna be your sky bird
I mean there's never gonna be a Johnson
or Smith [ __ ] that communist yarmulke
why people like oh my god they leave
comments and they always sign up for the
email yeah always
why people are everybody's guestbook
when the show is always like arm I
noticed you didn't mention anything
about you guessable
is there place where I can sign up for
your newsletter black people just like
how did you know about [ __ ] told who
told you about the chonta streets [ __ ]
the streets you miss when you see um do
you like sometimes when I miss like old
school black guys like now it seem like
a lot of the black guys are like a
little softer like a little bit like I
saw black hours glasses the other day
like you'll see it's nothing wrong with
you know that's so disrespectful son
there's nothing wrong with the glasses
everybody is some party like probably
wear glasses you know the disrespectful
[ __ ] they always gotta let you
think is this level of intellect when
they just keep pushing it up oh yeah I
hate the ones that like enforcer play
like like let me taste yeah and if those
people in glasses but you shouldn't you
you know just because a black person
wear glasses
I don't think you should for me the
other pin you know about them because of
that [ __ ] got a read bro yeah
you know I miss real [ __ ] I feel like it
was it seemed like it was just different
black kids when I was growing up in
there are now you know like they had a
black guy with the other day with asthma
that I met in that [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all
every blabbers I knew growing up here
and grew up growing up had asthma really
yo when you live in the projects with
metal you gonna have some respiratory
issues do you gotta go to Cleveland
anywhere new your glam pipe [ __ ] you
asthma's all right yo your fairies are
smoking Newports in the bathroom you
gonna have an asthma pump
and that's what you want no real [ __ ]
oh you ain't oh not as bad as
[ __ ]
well your asthma had better have some
asthma around his [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude we had a girl named asthma Wilson -
in our junior high
what about asthma yeah but why people
have allergies yeah who said he was
feeling dizzy bro yo
I'll tell you man they have allergies
right your allergies and maybe I'll just
be known I can't get on a flight now
without so why person stopping me from
getting artistic bag of peanuts man get
its mother [ __ ] train brah you don't
say hey guys hey 300 people are my
Michael Michael Michael
Urban which I'm not give up white as day
has an allergy problem to peanuts so now
nobody get peanuts get the [ __ ] out of
here with an Alan [ __ ] that man
but what about this though you are you
do um when I was young like now they
have more it seemed like black diseases
like when I was young they had diabetes
was popular that still strong blood
pressure right that still strong it
would out but now there's other stuff
you know it's like other you know
there's a black guy had chicken pox I
remember your ass [ __ ] what is
that was in Vietnam yeah but they got yo
you should get chicken pox in the United
States side yo yo yo your health care is
not upside that [ __ ] is only opposed to
be Africa and muhfucka Haiti and
Thailand you should not be able to get
chickenpox in America but I'm just
saying black people are getting like
weak diseases that used to be only white
people we get it seems like that's
something you know like the only black
diseases not known isn't it some it's
gonna always stay in this test the time
is the itis yeah you know every I think
every black person I've ever went school
were to grow with all head to itis
it is the itis is um it's the it's like
autism now I just it's something like
you know like in the black community
where okay let's say you eat a lot of
food you get tired one take oh yeah you
know I'm saying that white people have a
name for doing Thanksgiving it's
something that's released in Turkey
tryptophan tryptophan courtesy in a
white guy knew there was a glad you like
now know what you say you know but
that's one disease is very very very
strong the black comedians it's never
gonna be a cure for what relaxes the
itis yeah when you get the itis know
like when you eat a lot and then you
feel yeah you usually get it from stuff
like like like like steaks yeah
cheeseburger ribs ribs if you eat ribs
it's like that's like you and you induce
and you make it happen to yourself
yeah but black people gonna have had the
ideas for years and probably continue to
have eyes and I know that um I know that
uh Reverend Al Sharpton's at a point is
like he's a vegan right now so you know
really yeah he's good is that how do
y'all treat that that seems not like a
black thing in a black community we
think I noticed it so [ __ ] up if you
vegan we think you get to say yeah you
don't and I play another man I feel you
and I came in like just change in your
diet yeah you could be popular so
homophobic like change your diet could
cause someone like you know I'm saying
go to like a hamburger spot what black
do and you order your cheeseburger with
like blue Allah would like Swiss cheese
or cottage cheese baby wrong they'll be
they'll be on that cottage cheese Swiss
cheese blue cheese if you order blue
cheese and if you want cheese arrested
gateway drug it did but they don't be on
a that's a great way they happen to fall
out yo this [ __ ] chain sir I
just caught this [ __ ] eating
with his burden I'm not cheese not that
he chose it better cheese but I caught
him eating yeah you don't put mayonnaise
on your burger you gonna be some and you
don't gotta answer to me you gotta
answer to the street yeah is that the
life you want if that's not that's the
perception you want people have of you
did you eat burgers with Swiss cheese
and cottage cheese bros bruh straight up
Kraft deluxe all day
represent Brooklyn you know that's just
it
what's up guys I want to tell you about
the world's thinnest phone case
that's right sometime you have a phone
case and it's too big you can't even get
it out of your pocket you can't even get
your phone out of your car because your
case is so big
well now that can change it's the
world's thinnest phone case the minimal
case that's right it's point zero one
inches thick it sounds unbelievable it
is not now this isn't a case that you
could throw your phone in water in
that's for sure but it is the world's
thinnest phone case it's available for
all major phones including iPhone x87
pixel to Galaxy Note 8 Galaxy S 9 plus
and the new iPhone X's XR and new pixel
threes that are in stock and you can get
a special Black Friday sale 30% off with
the discount code Theo 30 that's th EO
number three number zero for 30% off
just go to M in ml case calm and use
promo code th EO number three number
zero that's MN ml case CAS e-comm yeah
man I think I can be I think if I was if
you were if you're mixed is it better to
have a black mom or a white mom and a
black dad or white that like what's the
ideal Gus arrest him because I that's a
tough one because I have friends that on
both sides of the mix equality okay you
know I'm saying I just think um I think
that the Dhobis thing because we like
when you're when you're a mix kid like
people ordered mag like you're black
yeah you know say now yeah I dated I
dated this this chick and she was
biracial her mom was why I entered a I
was black you know and then one thing I
respected about her is that she
respected on both sides of her family
yeah it wasn't just just like black this
she understood you know I mean she she
understood that she was black she
understood she was white you know we
would go out her wife
made sure we were always on time oh yeah
yeah you know I'm saying like we were we
were always ahead of everybody and
that's when I connect with her Whiteside
but at the same time the black side her
we would be early but we would have a
home a housewarming gift yeah you don't
say you not me but Fred but I think made
it up that's a tough one I just think
like in the case of parents or to
different backgrounds it's good to
represent both both both sides of em
both sides yeah yeah that's interesting
man yeah I think sometimes there's
always like yeah I always felt like I
wanted to maybe I don't know if I wanted
to be black but I felt like I just I
don't know sometimes I wanted to relate
to some of those kids you know they just
seemed like they were having more fun
they seemed braver than me when I was
young like some of the black guys that I
knew how was it did you did you I know
you were locked up phone we left for
hours yeah but did you did you meet any
black friends in here oh I wouldn't say
friends they had a couple of dudes is a
good one black dude dress everybody
called him dress and it was short the
transvestite I don't I think they call
him dressed to kill but he wore dress no
Nicole dress and he he looked like the
kind of dude that was just gonna [ __ ]
everybody but only around the holidays
you know he seemed like all year he
stays yeah what he liked he seemed like
something just came like his dick was
hibernating all year and then it did G
did you get a gangster name why you were
locked up like thug like Theo or
anything like that no some of the
Latinos brought you was scary in there
these days
Latinos bro oh yeah Latinos good luck
Tino's they black dudes were trying to
look Mexican brother they have black
dudes in there like kind of trying to
lighten their skin it was trial against
what they had a home before they do have
to Orange
now black people don't [ __ ] with Latinos
Mary what is that are you guys scared of
Latinos do be honest
yeah I'll say like I like those in 32
yeah or em 15 I don't know what number
it is yeah but like when I was growing
up between DC and I was in Virginia the
El Salvadorian community was coming in
strong really I think was a part of some
some civil rights I mean some some civil
war and he came here for asylum but for
some
they just migrated in this one one area
and we didn't know the difference where
we all it was only black and white yeah
but so anything I said that we call them
to foreigners
yeah and black people hang on front they
were scared up because they came over in
this country they didn't have guns they
have a saw they had machetes machete
yeah and when you start seeing trails of
thumbs and fingers yeah people not shoot
you shooting is one thing a shoot that
ain't gangsta anybody can shoot somebody
but when you actually have a piece of
metal yeah and you look at my face it
twisted that was skittish [ __ ] out of a
by black people don't mess with the m13
Russians bro Russians are crazy bro yeah
what is it about him they don't have any
I think it was rocky man a rocky movie
we got us upset man it wasn't a movie
Russians don't have dude I heard some a
friend of mine told me that there were
kids and Russia the girls would have
dolls made of a stone imagine that and
you never seem to be quite honest you
don't Russia's you've never seen a
Russian cry no on any situation I just
got that heart that rock exterior man
people stay away from that man my people
not messing with the Russians and then
that mess with no as Salvadorians them
13 no disrespect to the number I forget
yeah what number 13 why people know why
people know to know we have a chart at
helmet Uddin yeah what number not to
mess with well it says like it you know
they have that like fire chart where
it's like today's fire warning is yellow
you know we have that like today's
racial warning is and then it's whoever
we're supposed to be aware I mean it
that because I'm afraid of certain
people myself do what about Asian people
when I see it like how do black and
Asian people relate to each other cuz I
have no concept of that you know a black
agent people get along as long as it's
not situation where black person's going
a grocery store
cuz it doesn't really matter how much of
a friend you are but you're robbing a
person no no they're gonna follow you
they'll follow you ladies will get it
follow you
you'll follow you Oh in the grocery
store but also though all those movies
where the black guys come in and shoot
up the grocery store probably has a lot
of those Asian counter people skate I
don't know those movies yeah really I
don't know they just come and shoot up
the grocery store what more is that yeah
I think you just made it up bro what
news am I
this the situation with Asians being
prime military in stationed in Korea oh
yeah yeah that's a different perception
what what agents hate about Western
civilization the most is having no
respect for elders mmm you know I'm
saying when I was when I was stationed
career in the Air Force that's one thing
it didn't matter what your financial
status was whatever you had a certain
level of respect just because my person
was older than you yeah you know saying
no matter where you from whatever and
then when they come over here and then
they see like and it's not just for
black people any kid like it's America
for this America and they said you being
disrespectful to elder I think they
can't really they can't really connect
with that you know because I have some
really cool Korean friends that because
they know to my background in the Asian
community in Korea they know that I
understand things that upset them there
I got love yeah yeah that's interesting
yeah cuz I guess one thing that I never
one thing you never learn about is just
how like different all I kind of knew
growing up was just like how like black
and white you were kind of relating to
each other like we didn't have enough
diversity and you never hear about that
like I never know how like blacks and
Latinos relate to each other or you know
or our Asian people do but I think this
will do how it should be how we should
relate to stuff at the end of day no
matter what your color is no matter what
your sexual preference is you got good
people and bad people yeah
you're not saying in like yeah that's
really you don't mean as much as
devadutt
as our country our country is it's not
like that everywhere I agree I'm saying
you are not we're good friends you know
we see each other in the club whatever
sometimes we have differences I love
talking to you know his mother stuff but
at the end of the day at the end of day
we have respect for each other yeah you
don't said like I don't even with our
past election you know sense some people
I don't never understand how people get
upset because somebody chose to vote for
every chose to vote for yeah you know
I'm saying that's your choice but this
past election was interesting because a
lot of people upset the resolution black
people were upset Asian people have said
gay people are upset but white people
were really upset yeah yeah
the difference with white people and
black people angle was black people
anyways protests of black lives matter
and white people's I okay we'll see
about that in the morning they pull
their pants up put their pants up and
they went to the polls
yeah I'm saying and anytime you see a
white person do like just hey I don't
care if his politics or whatever it's
going to be so change
yeah I'm telling you if a white presents
like yeah yeah this might be some change
but exercise your right to vote and you
make a change
you know what that is but do black
people low-key you guys have got a love
Donald Trump because he has like a hot
why am I tell you he's like he's like
he's like a dragger part of his poetry
in a rap video it seems like don't put
this what people don't understand about
the hold on Ashanti black people used to
love Donald Trump yeah in the 90s almost
every rapper when yous connected
something with a lifestyle yeah like
Playboy baddest [ __ ] Queens women no
disrespect
don't meet to me on that yeah well you
know you're the the lifestyle they
wanted right the baddest chicks the
baddest car the baddest house the money
to yachts and everything that's what
everybody was rapping about and who had
that type of [ __ ] that was from Donald
Trump did you know I'm saying Donald
Trump would Donald Trump would it would
be what do cameos in videos are yeah but
that's the that's the Donald Trump that
they knew that what not so much he cared
about black people but he was a fun guy
party turned up right and it wasn't
until even when Donald Trump was on um
on on Dona princess yeah they saw a
shark somebody was hungry he saw some I
was successful they were admired they
admired that but it wasn't until the
ugliness came yeah you don't say it
wasn't until the Uglies came that people
started switching him not just black
people but other ppl well turned off by
him his attitude but he is here's the
thing Donald Trump
totes the economy yeah there's the
unemployment black job rate and
everything
he he he he totes how well the economy
is doing you know Instagram I posted
something someone said well the last
time I checked
economy was doing well and my answer to
that person was
don't confuse economy with humanity
right and it's hard
our chairs and roof for somebody with
the success he's having when you create
such a diverse situation
your [ __ ] want to be happy
right yeah but we want to be happy for
he kind of at the same time you should
know on John McCain you [ __ ] on
right you were heroes he's not a good
he's not a he does not yeah he makes you
as a person you don't it's hard to
really it's hard you gotta serve people
always like jobs jobs jobs first of all
I don't subscribe to the notion that
there aren't jobs in America I agree if
it wasn't jobs American you wouldn't
have [ __ ] over here swimming
being on rest and everything to get here
these jobs the whole thing is Americans
are selective of the jobs they want yeah
yeah I'm saying you can get a job you
know I'm saying now it might money job
might not be the job that you want but
you can get a job not being to get a job
in America is Bill lying I get I'm
saying like you know and in certain
communities like certain communities a
job would even make it yeah like in the
hood a job could walk in the hood yeah
shake a [ __ ] big hey who is
this I'm a job and the brother wake up
like this man what the [ __ ] you doing
here anybody looking for you man go down
to Home Depot they looking for you down
there bad
I thought you was the weed yeah so it's
that wasn't any inspiration they manatee
the flip side of okay narrow but we got
jobs you got job there people look for
you don't saying you got jobs and I'm
sick and me personally some people just
mad at a party right I'm not mad I'm not
mad at or I'm not like that I'm not mad
I would have no issue with a Republican
president that had some more of a
moderate yeah you know I'm saying
someone understood because I'm better
stirred humanity he doesn't he doesn't
understand people he doesn't yeah he
does not have a comfortable tone with
people he doesn't because he's probably
never he probably was never really cared
about much growing up like in a way
where he felt it you know never felt
what someone else is going through like
sliced like even with this stuff with
the with these [ __ ] the campfire in LA
whatever you know when people yes that
crazy you can't say some of that stuff
you can't invest and then he says it
yeah and then people gravity
and it's so [ __ ] up because I know
friends that have friends that vote for
Donald Trump and they say as much as I
still want to be friends now it's just
hard for me to connect with somebody
that like loved someone's with that
energy yeah you know saying in and it
doesn't it doesn't have to be that yeah
he was a phenom yeah the same way Barack
Obama was he was a phenom you know I'm
saying but the first great thing to me
is like women when Obama is in office he
took his lumps
he was like Bush this Bush that Bush
days okay I got it from me I take from
here yo Trump you want don't be a sore
loser yeah why do you have to like this
in a hood keep my name out your mouth
why do you got to keep on trying to
knock yeah he does a lot of that if you
think about it if you think about it
Obama's campaign slogan and Trump's
paint paint campaign slowly meant the
same thing if anything if you think
about it when when when Obama was
running he could have ran on the slogan
of make America great again yeah you
know me his definition would probably be
a lot better than Donald Trump's right
and that's right either one could edit
one and Donald Trump could add change it
could have had change and both of them
were like scoping them with both of them
was like like just these candidates that
they needed something different yeah
people like my friend Donald Trump's
based felt like he needed something they
needed something different yeah you know
I'm Sam when Bush was with the transit
from Bush to Obama
it didn't matter who the [ __ ] we came
president they needed something
different so both of them they was the
they was the rock stars you know in this
much a moment there was a rock star
moment glad I black people get upset
like just look at like this you lived in
a life a lifetime where you saw a black
president and not just a black president
you saw a good guy you saw the president
and you you saw a president you felt
cared about everything and everybody
right is it that's interesting yeah you
definitely feel ya with with Obama you
felt like he cared you know like I voted
for Obama twice you know and like and
you felt like he cared right now one of
my friends he was a CEO of this of this
just tech companies Silicon Valley he
was like in this black guy he's it done
at first off you know there's no reason
he's like like a Hillary was a flawed
candidate she was flawed
you don't yeah she's like yeah she was
she was flawed and people hated her so
much that it showed love toward in a
favor down shop but this is another
thing too and this is so important you
started changed with the midterms and
everything is that people have to
understand the importance of voting and
like making oh I agree
Emma takes on one thing as much as a
helicopter deplorable and people talk
about these rednecks and these
[ __ ] these rest days whatever
one thing and this no disrespect but
like somebody this trailer trash trailer
park type stuff and one thing they don't
they always want exercise these are
right the world they don't have to have
teeth they don't have to have jobs they
don't have to have anything in life but
they're gonna exercise but don't know
how you do change yeah but don't you
think like I feel like sometimes like
people are somehow they've got us all
tricked in some ways these parties
because you know black people have voted
Democrat for a long time poor white poor
black people have voted Democrat for a
long time poor white people have voted
Republican for a long time but it's like
how long do we keep voting those ways
well dump we're and we're and we're
still in the same trough yeah but the
thing is that you're gonna vote for
whatever party well that's hard it's our
cross over to get it's hard up cross
over to get what most black community to
even think on public side I do
understand it but it's gonna be somebody
that has your similar views in your and
your ideas yeah because even on the
Republican side um Jeb Bush yeah I was a
fan of his and the reason why was a
friend of his because I understand it
hears from the Bush family but he felt
like the mama's boy right you don't
saying he felt like the P felt like the
bush that would have had heart enough to
say this is wrong this is wrong what I'm
saying
he's the one that I would say would
probably be a Republican that ships
closer to the moderate side to anything
yeah Sam I was a fan of his but being a
president now it's not all about who you
thinking heart is to charisma as a charm
and how do you pop yeah
and he couldn't pop it's turning into
WWE a little bit you know that you feel
like everything's kind of turning into
the wrestling yeah it's on it's on for
what what is it's like like everything
now it's really like a reality show it's
really like that like you knowing how to
manipulate the media right you know I'm
saying you know how to manipulate the
media you could win at anything and this
was proven with Donald Trump being
president was he the best candidate was
the best president for a job not so much
yeah but he knew how to work the media
he knew I say they say bill he knew how
to get money compared to um American
Idol how do you get people like yellow
tick sauce over you winner he knew how
to make people he know how to excite
them he know how to make people move and
go do something but in some ways isn't
it didn't you feel a little bit after
you got elected like holy [ __ ] man I
could be President did you feel that for
a second like [ __ ] anybody could be
President yeah but um I really felt I
really felt more of that when um Obama
was press because that was the one I
could see that that's the one excuse
black people that we people hold on to
you can say anything yes so so yeah
bored ain't gonna never be no black
doctors we got more black doctors
it'll be no black astronauts we got
black astronaut they do it yeah we got
black everything this was the only thing
yeah that we didn't have you know saying
so for all of my people don't make
excuses when Obama got elected it's like
he proved that there's no more excuses
yeah and even when the Obama I know said
none to economy even when um Obama I
went to bar all black people wasn't
happy about Obama right everyone's a
Barbra shot one time and I'm this
brother day was talking he's like he
don't um photo bomb I was like he was
alia what if he said what is Barack
Obama definite black people and I looked
do I say he one [ __ ] yeah you
don't say was he gonna be a great
president nobody knew him no god I don't
think anybody can be a great president
yeah but the fact that he won shows you
that it's inspiring it's inspiring but
the trick of that was like every black
person thought they're gonna be
president right here's a dude I just you
know Obama black up black he played
basketball you know I could do that [ __ ]
no you still got to stay out of trouble
you still got to have an education yeah
and you still got to be a dope citizen
you can't just like because I'm black do
you can do it so yeah that excitement
was done sometimes I think about it to
me and this is just a perception of mine
and I
and this could be ignorance - it seems
to me that or sometimes I think or I
feel that yeah that the that the black
some of the black community like there
is a ton of opportunity these days and
some of the things the only thing that I
feel like holds some black people back
is just their lack of desire in some
place that's man just because that's
what anybody right anybody
and after why do you think I see that
why do you think I feel I feel or see
that more or as a white person or why do
you think because um and I'm not I'm not
around you doesn't got this you're
probably not around enough black people
that don't make excuses right you know
I'm saying if you limit yourself to a
couple of people a handful of people you
don't see digs and I grew up in the
south and there wasn't when there's no
opportunity of course like the South is
a different animal a little bit because
there's decades and generations no I'm
gonna so I'm believing it like there are
noise here's a thing you have two
excuses yeah you have a good excuse as a
bad excuse and the internet is to
excuses as a comic you know I'm saying
you can have a show like at night at 12
o'clock you just found out like one of
your aunts or uncle's or whatever just
passed away right you got a good excuse
not to go to that show you know you know
I'm it's not I'm not feeling right
that's my excuse is still excuse and you
got a bad excuse and had to go to a show
you know I'm saying oh man I got a cold
or something something stupid you know
but at the end of day is still excuses
so as much as we're we not just black
people and just for anybody stop making
excuses
yeah it's so easy to make excuse what
you gonna do what you gonna do and that
goes I relate that to comedy you see
you've been in a game for a long time
you see my [ __ ] trying to get stage
time and stuff and they say oh yeah but
they don't really like me in that Club
they don't really mess with women and
then you access same comic where do you
before I perform I just won clubs over
mic and you say how did you do all my
set was okay no [ __ ] that ain't
enough yeah you know I'm saying and I
tell his all young comments with you
know any any doors you want opened it's
gonna come through the microphone yeah
when you rippin when you're not just
5050 I'm trouble you demolishing
everywhere you
can't be denied yeah you don't say don't
make excuses make yourself undeniable
you don't mean okay I don't do five
spots a week I do too but we need to
know two spots kill him yeah those two
spots are turned into three spots and
five spots I've even used myself as an
example with me in the comedy scene in
California I came up with New York on
when I first came in people knew me from
the Chappelle show right they don't need
a lot of people didn't know me to
standing but a lot of clubs didn't know
oh he's a funny dude on TV but whatever
and I used to drive down Sunset
Hollywood and now you see the names up
there on it on the marquee yeah and I'm
look at those names and I'm not
disrespecting them like this I'm on that
level right I'm gonna be Leah I'm not
I'm not making excuses I'm not gonna say
[ __ ] that
I don't want to do the computer do the
work to get there and graduate I told
myself I want to be what I'm in town I
want to be on every marquee that's a
test of who's popping in the city yeah
and it might not mean a lot to a lot of
people but for me when I can drive down
sunset and I see I'm on the marquee at
the store go to laughs Agra see I'm on
the marquee laughs at you go to the
Improv I'll say I'm at the marquee at
the improv go to her house was it caught
a lot of people don't [ __ ] with this
place yeah this is a great place where
God when you see that you feel a
comments and you feel accomplished and
you sell yourself I didn't make excuses
and I deal with it a couple times like
oh they don't want to they don't wanna
let me on and it let that [ __ ]
one right you just take your lumps come
back the next day and you build your
[ __ ] yeah and the reason I'm saying is
like in life period
there are literally there's no more
excuses
that's true maybe you wanna do it you're
not gonna do it yeah and you look around
as we got too many examples I mean
outfield we got examples of people that
we don't necessarily agree with like say
from stand-up but you got now we are we
in an age where you could make yourself
the [ __ ] on your phone yeah in front of
your computer it's not the time when I
came I was three or four networks we're
on your own network so you definitely
you got people that six nine is a
perfect example yeah it wasn't trying to
[ __ ] with him the energy went from [ __ ]
with him we say I'm gonna [ __ ] myself
I don't need y'all feet yeah that's a
great segment I'm gonna [ __ ] up myself
yeah
[ __ ] myself and I could make a habit you
know yeah I don't know I had a manager
before I don't have a manager right now
and I had a manager and I run one time I
had this thing I was trying to do when I
was traveling on the road and I was
having and I was like I want to shoot it
and put it on a YouTube and he's like
well let's put it together and go out
and shop it around so then we did that
for like a year and nobody you know it
was back and forth but in the meantime
in that year I didn't you know I did it
some but I was waiting now more - for
these networks to decide if I was gonna
have an opportunity whereas if I would
have just been making at the time that's
they would have been huge then it would
have been something at the finish line
whereas instead I let them decide okay
the finish line is now and we don't want
to add your own thing yeah I'll give you
two great examples of that bill burr
Kevin Hart when I was doing when we were
doing Chappelle show at the time bill
Burt was bubbling bill burr was bubbling
he wasn't can say that ten times fast
no no reason why I'm saying that yeah
now he was bubbling yeah I saw him in
the club he was like you go see certain
clubs do you like this this month I was
gonna blow this [ __ ] gonna blow
but he didn't have to do TV and all that
but you know what's coming right and we
were just repel show we were making
money spell show but not a lot of money
we needed a tour I came up with the idea
of doing a ton rich [ __ ] to her yeah
you know I'm saying in a rich [ __ ] tore
the the two two drawers at the time with
me and Charlie and I could have ran what
they I could have went to my local but I
said not bill burr is an animal let's
not just do a show people coming for the
novelty of the show yeah let's give them
a show where this show is fire from
beginning to end and that's what we had
on rich [ __ ] tour I think this is the
first time Bill burr was we were we ran
this shift like a year and a half
Charlie Murphy would bill Burt you know
you know this is funny bill burr was a
feature
Wow and I was headlining and I'll tell
you you know you talk about no excuses
imagine going on every night for a year
behind bill burr thought that there was
no day you could take off yeah you
didn't have a you go out and party get
all [ __ ] up you got a hangover the
next day guess what happened and this
happened to be able advertise like yeah
it was funny but that white boy you
don't I'm saying and a point I'm making
is he knew his features foods come
because Mia try was on
ah yes it was just it was pandemonium
but bill burr wasn't one with the
comment cards you know I'm saying
filling him out de bills I'm not yo you
worry about the email [ __ ] making people
who become easier forever
he was dude they was doing the email car
and he started building that base yeah
he stopped doing that base and then when
you start on that base
people started riding with you and then
you because then you win
like comedian of the Year in the
Montreal Comedy Festival you gonna build
to that point he knew what he wanted
early on a lot of people don't Kevin
Hart as much as people want to touch
about Kevin Hart Kevin Hart was the same
situation Kevin Hart was always down
with whatever didn't the newest thing
was was myspace right I remember Kevin
Hart has 60,000 followers on Twitter he
was trying but he just follows now that
dudes out of he just on another level
yeah rock star but he planted that and
like you were saying about waiting for
the networks they didn't wait those
people didn't wait so by time the
network's got caught up to them they was
already I was entranced it was not ready
ready you know I'm saying and that's
what you said is important you know I'm
saying but like a lot of times in this
business we want to swing for the gate
all the time yeah sometime a base hit is
good sometime a bun is good but you got
to know that yeah and that's what
separates two different people now you
look at Bill burr I look at Bill burr 13
years ago best he was on he was a
opening on our show and then is just
doing doing Madison Square Garden and
this is another thing how stuff's
supposed to inspire you I see that I
know how funny am I know how funny is it
but it gives you a sense of Noda you
from a place where it could happen right
you know I'm saying you look at Bill
burr he's like this do we were saying it
could happen who's gonna put the work in
right you know do you where do you get
some of your own work ethic man because
it's really interesting because
especially you were cut like I mean I'm
you know you're a little bit old me I'm
38 you know but when I was growing up
the own like they didn't have like you
know they had you know our town was
maybe you know my environment is
probably like half black and half white
kids and a lot of them didn't have like
a lot of you know leadership or
direction they probably did have a lot
of you know role models and stuff you
know and I knew that because I didn't
have a lot of it so I would spend time
around a lot of those kids so
where did you get and a lot of them were
a done with school at seventh grade or
eighth grade I mean done you know 70
percent of the black kids in our school
were gone at eighth grade you know right
I think in the south that was just you
know it's just a different it was a
different place and this is you know 20
years ago 25 years ago but where did you
get like what kind of kept you in a
different Lane to have you know at least
some of the you know mental capacity you
know that you had when you were young do
you think well my my mom my mom was a
very very loving mom my dad was a guy
that was in and out of jail you know my
dad was a he was a heroin kingpin in DC
and black people always loved the fact
that they could tell what level your dad
got to he was a big-time and he chose
lights-out where he didn't get a lot of
chance to spend with his kids like he
wanted but my mom always is still um
loved yeah she she was honest she wasn't
like upset that she was raised as pretty
much so she never made excuses she spent
time with us
at the Internet at the Internet at the
time did your parents spend with the
kids if you see any kid that's like kind
of outline and crazy whatever you know
it might be cases where it's not that
way you could break it down yeah you
could break down at all I see why mom
always had a babysitter yeah I was in
the club you know he always saw mom come
home with the just got smashed outfit so
like that I can contribute you know the
kids know ya know I know our kids feel
something yeah I can triple contribute a
lot of that and I don't know if it's
work ethics as much as just thought on
life yes a my mom obviously say you know
we don't have like it always can be it
you know it's a lot of people that's
doing a lot worse and we're kind of you
can do better you know but I just think
that my mom just created the type of
love in the environment that I only
wanted to do well and I not cared about
what she thought and I always wanted to
make my mother proud
yeah some people don't give a [ __ ] about
what the parents think about him I want
to make my mother proud and even my
father was locked up a lot of my life I
want to make him proud yeah I want to be
him to be proud of the fact that I'm
creating a lifestyle and doing something
I love to do and I'm not in prison I'm
not doing something take a Jeff
jeopardize my freedom yeah so a lot of
just wanting to do better and just
wanting to be great even when I started
coming I never thought about money or
anything all I wanted to do was be the
baddest [ __ ] yeah and at the end
the day if YouTube as my [ __ ] you know
the money I catch with that
yeah damn man you got me [ __ ] feeling
all emotional and [ __ ] man do why do
white people feel more emotional at like
black movies that are like triumphant
they don't feel more emotion everybody
desu man no they just know that white
people will express their emotions a lot
faster than black people you know Sam
black be so afraid of being hurry or
what some I don't think you like you
like in a black neighborhood and the
black community growing up the first
thing you tell everybody don't cry right
oh you know you suck
don't cry shake it off you don't say yes
I got hit by two cars don't cry yo yeah
that's a good point brah can't remember
seeing that so many times as a kid yeah
don't cry white white folks all right
let's talk about it to me is everything
okay yeah you know I'm saying like you
just we just I don't know where it comes
from but we just built to be tough about
everything you know yeah I don't get it
now feeling son yeah don't get enough
feelings you know if you can you feeling
you go smack somebody like yo I'm with I
almost cried smack yourself yeah
money trade like all days dang man
that's exciting bruh this exciting man
what else can we talk about a question
that came in that came in for done now
we're gonna play it is it in headphones
or is it video it'll be in headphones
okay man I wish I was on that tour dude
it'd be fun whenever I got to go on this
the road with you maybe we could come up
with something I wonder I really would
love to do a sitcom or something my and
her sons write it write it we bro if we
took it in we could do it no we could
not only do it we could [ __ ] it up
because um things are about to switch
you know you have people's getting
opportunities I'm not saying that
deserving of him but there just ain't
putting it up putting it writing it in
you know I get your shot but we get your
shot you hit a three you have a dunk I
think we could do it yeah I promise in
Texas are you wanna call in for Darnell
dog
I don't want to say it's [ __ ] up how
they joke on here on The Breakfast Club
like every making me feel bad and like
I'm like god amighty god do my boy like
that but everybody just got black or
white first of all he watchin he listen
to black Breakfast Club he's black
okay so he sings no it's so funny you
say that because wherever I go now
people always like they say the same
thing why you let the brother Breakfast
Club [ __ ] you like The Breakfast Club
don't [ __ ] like that they can't [ __ ]
with me like that but who people cheer
for me you know even you know a lot of
us say you don't say they cheer for me
so as much as as much as as much as they
[ __ ] with me I know the funny story line
and you [ __ ] with me
yeah and me spoiling you see in the
bigger storyline a bigger picture yeah
and like and I used to have issues I
just have issues with Charlemagne he's
tried it or he's not funny bla bla bla
bla until he came to Madison Square
Garden over for Dave Chappelle and I he
saw me open for Dave Chappelle and I
cordis Stan you know yeah front of 6,500
people
I stood up the whole that masters going
Radio City Music Hall and I couldn't
wait to do the next interview with him
on The Breakfast Club yeah and he was
like yo now for nothing Donnell you in
in shock I mean yeah and I was like this
where you been
you know say and I could have been mad
at Charlemagne in the hall let's talk
about [ __ ] you I'm not funny I was like
nope where'd you come in my arena right
and then that's one speak see what I do
yeah but I appreciate what you just said
knows that I've noticed people this team
downhill and they like what I'm doing so
we I'm always gonna be the fourth member
of that show and I'm always gonna have
fun with them in the end of the day
that's my family I got love and respect
for all of them but we're here to make
comedy and make it make it make
entertainment is it fun to go in there
is like on Breakfast Club is it is it
intimidating in that environment you
don't get intimidated does he like it's
easy for me because I used to do morning
radio oh wow so I had a back I had a
background I would do morning radio envy
you know I do morning radio in his way
when I come on here it's sometimes what
after I get off the show I'm like what I
didn't promote this I didn't promote
that but when I'm up there it's almost
like I'm a part of the show yeah you
don't say I could really be on this show
right it fits in yeah I don't they don't
use not like you're a guest it's like
you just kind of get in
feeling like when I go in a like people
could you know like some people get
sense of he's down eggs in that question
but I can navigate that conversation in
any way I want to but I miss doing radio
and they have respect for me and not
going in and I just said I think I'm the
most interview guest on that show that's
that's amazing it is it's a lot and it's
tough because I had to go through people
you know the trolls like damn y'all
can't get them work yes how many times
just me only only show but did I you
know I'm seeing where's my cap set yeah
I was just let it right right and what
people started say was like he brings a
different energy to the show mm-hmm and
we he's on his show
he's always funny so I could be on that
[ __ ] every other week yeah as
long as I represent him be funny that's
it yeah was it is it did Charlemagne
have a big like is he seem like he has a
big ego or is he chill dude I never met
the man now he wasn't I love their show
though I'll watch it now he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't have a big in you but
eat ego ego sorry about this you know
but you know you get a certain sway yeah
yeah when you start getting a certain
mass success yeah I mean more people
love you
the more people you just say you know I
don't really give a [ __ ] yeah I'm saying
I don't think it's egos it's telling me
it's more swag yes it's more swag he's
that he's a a person that doesn't bite
his tongue that's what people like about
he don't bite his tongue he gonna say
how I feel a lot of people don't agree
with it but he doesn't waver from who he
is he doesn't well yeah and that's why
he like yeah you know and he can't [ __ ]
with me no Pam from Pam really it's
gonna joke when you're going to no not
on a joke no but if you guys had to
wrassle or something would you do it
I'm of the age where I don't take
chances on [ __ ] like yeah I learned my
lesson I try to dunk on an eight-foot
best part like two years ago
I pop my patella and that's even
physical is over if he's had treadmill
where I could jump in a jump off and I
also have two fights that were captured
on TMZ that I didn't come I didn't
connect so I don't want that three
strike I'm just go stay away from that
[ __ ] that's when you go get the strap
get the goons with my goals usually have
Jewish male so I'm not right you the
street you see you in court
[ __ ] these Israelites yeah notice it's
definitely changed
your mother's in town for the holidays
you know my friend my family's on the
East Coast yeah yeah I have extended my
brother one of my brothers um
he's here so I'm gonna have Thanksgiving
with him nice does your uh do you make
your mom laughs always yeah I always
make my mother laugh my mother not make
my mother laugh and some of the most
painful moments you know I'm saying like
that's just without feeling I was it's
like it could be a dark situation yeah
you always can find a place to land I
remember one of the things that pushed
me in the direction economy late at
night when I was making my mother laugh
and she was like boy
don't tell another joke unless you're
gonna make some money doing it mmm and
that started me to think about it and
then I think shortly after that I
started doing yeah yeah it's nice when a
kid can make their mom laugh I think it
makes them feel good you know
yeah if you can't make your mom laughter
you might think of a different because
you call the puzzle after everything
your mother was laughing say you the
most handsome person you must be the
best-looking person in your mom's face
in her eyes and everything yo yo what
type of if you don't get that support
from your mom's done you bought to buy
that stock pump or rifle bro why does it
seem like all tall black guys if they
don't play ball they work at the airport
is that a real thing or is that just my
that is funny I don't know maybe they're
good at putting the bags I don't know
that's fun because you 617 you ain't
plan your life for the rest your life
you six ain't no do you guys start
making that [ __ ] I played in China tore
my ACL and then I just I got a job at
the airport we'll have your will put
your tour dates and stuff at the front
yes so people will know about it um
happy Thanksgiving donnell rawlings
Thanksgiving good to see you brother
yeah you too man thank you
[Music]
like these leaves I must be
little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe